My identity is not my obstacle.
Myidentity is my superpower.
I am just one of
millions of people
who have beentold that in
order to fulfill my dreams,
in order to contribute
my talents to the world
Ihave to resist the
truth of who I am.
I for one, am ready
to stop resisting
and to start existingas
my full and authentic self.
In spite of what I had
been told my whole life,
I saw firsthandthat my
unrealistic expectations
to see myself authentically
represented in the culture
wereother people’s
expectations, too.
Collectively, we are what
the world actually looks like.
And in order for our
systems to reflect that,
they don't have to
create a new reality.
They justhave to
stop resisting
the one we already live in.